because we had to use the studio new
studios being built working with a new
realtor
very excited about that who seems to be
a little bit more on the ball
from what we uh understand we've had
very bad luck with realtors across the
board oh wow yeah yeah very bad luck
everything and uh realtors
fall into two categories usually they
are um older menopausal women
uh that are suffering mild brain damage
from either a car accident or an
undiagnosed or self-diagnosed autoimmune
disorder
uh these women
are
uh usually
uh
middle-aged mid-age they're
on their second marriage
or
trying to keep the loveless first
marriage
and real estate for them might be a
second career or it may be a first
career that they kind of had while they
were raising their children
and
every new client
is a new husband for them
and they find a way to let every new
client down in the same way that they
let their husband down
over 30 years
and that's the what is this did you
pulled up this is an interesting
average age of an employed real estate
agent is 48. yeah the average age of an
employed real estate agent is 48 years
old so that's usually
it's a menopausal woman who's having hot
flashes
wants to [ __ ] ben
and i walk in behind him and go here's
the bad news i have all the money
and they basically make a big mess
out of everything you're trying to do
the other realtor is a young
jocular bro guy
who got into real estate because he
wants to crush it
he wants to [ __ ] crush it
and both of these people are incredibly
unhelpful when you're trying to get
something done
they're incredibly unhelpful the
menopausal woman deals
solely in the realm of emotions and says
things like yeah oh
hmm
well
uh i believe
what i think we can do here's what and
then the bro guys like yeah make it
happen
we're gonna [ __ ] make it happen get
it done neither one of them gets it done
yeah there's 156 000 real estate agents
currently employed in the united states
53
are women 42 percent are men
it is a women dominated field real
estate it is one of the fields that
women dominate as they should
many of them are very good at it but
many are not
and we've had some real
tough run-ins with real estate agents
you know my realtor out in palm springs
lovely woman lovely but fits the
demographic of what i talked about
uh
then we had the real estate agent agora
hills remember her same thing oh yeah we
had the realtor in malibu
similar thing yes uh incredibly bad in
her job do these windows up and i don't
know i mean just a lazy
person you know that had no
understanding of what she was doing from
day to day and
you know then we had uh the woman in
texas who was good she was probably the
best of all of them but still not
perfect
from you know not not
perfect but good better right i found
the house though that's what you don't
realize when you when you use a real
estate agent you actually do most of the
work
you do all of the work you find the
house
you call them up and you go please god
can we not lose this like we've done
three other times
and they go no not a problem we're gonna
get it
don't worry tim i'm gonna make it happen